ferrari porsche aston martin range-rover
des modèles rares étaient exposés au
domaine de madame elisabeth à versailles
ce week end les 25 et 26 avril une
exposition gratuite organisée dans le
cadre d'une vente aux enchères au rendez
vous a attiré plusieurs milliers
d'amoureux de belles mécaniques
avide de nostalgie à ya une belle rente
crover là bas qui est très jolie qui me
rappelle mon enfance les années 80 et a
que des vieux véhicules donc oui faut
ouais ouais ça rend nostalgique
la petite 205 gti élite 6/4 jeune
j'avais une 205 gti et 8,9 sur laquelle
j'ai appris à conduire en fait ça parle
au coeur tout à fait au total 25
véhicules de collection étaient
présentés au public avant la vente
il ya un peu de tout on essaye d'avoir
aussi un parc automobile assez assez
mélangé dans le sens où il ya pour tous
les prix pour toutes les envies pour
tous les goûts surtout il ya autant de
d'anciennes et de de très anciennes
notre première vient 2000 date de 1947
mais également de youngtimers avec des
collecteurs d futur collector qui ne
sont pas encore les voitures de
collection la bmw z3 où la porsche 996
qui va forcément trouvé preneur à des
petits prix après l'exposition place à
la vente ce dimanche 26 avril toujours à
versailles dans cette maison de vente
aux enchères une trentaine d'acheteurs
s'est déplacé s'est laissé tenter la
plupart des 25 lots sont partis ça a été
même au delà de nos espérances avec un
très beau look s'est vendu l'aston
martin dbs qui est parti pour 142 mille
euros marteau auxquels il faut rajouter
20 % de frais donc c'est une très grande
surprise pour les vendeurs comme pour
nous on est très heureux
les autres lots sont bien partis
notamment sur internet et aussi des
acheteurs en salle donc finalement là la
pandémie n'a pas n'a pas complètement
stoppé les ventes aux enchères
cette maison de vente organisera
d'autres ventes aux enchères de
véhicules de collection le prochain
rendez vous est programmé le 5 juillet
prochain toujours à versailles
[Applaudissements]